[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur TV 78 pour
une émission réalisé en direct dans le
cadre de la nouvelle édition du Skype
business en ce 25 novembre 6e édition du
Skype business des conventions
d'affaires toujours organisé par
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec pour
objectif de permettre aux entreprises de
développer la réseau à de mettre en
place de nouveau partenariat et nous
allons ajustement profité pour aborder
au cours de la prochaine heure le sujet
du collectif jouer collectif pour être
plus performant et c'est la thématique
de cette émission et j'accueille en
plateau tout d'abord Bernard Flament
Bonjour bonjour vous êtes le président
du réseau convergence avec vous
également Olivier par son bonjour vous
êtes le directeur de DVD ans bienvenue
également et Christophe merci d'être
venu pour cette émission directeur
général de général général j'ai Marie je
vais y arriver bon voilà nos trois
invités pour aujourd'hui et pour Vienne
et lustrer la thématique dans nous
allons parler regarde ensemble une
courte vidéo c'était en août 2014 lors
du relais féminin 4 x 400 m au
championnat d'Europe
Floria Guéi qui va prendre le bateau
pour la France sur les Russes ont-ils
attaqué la rue ils ont fini
[Applaudissements]
et
malheureusement ce sera ce sera pas
suffisant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Patrick j'ai jamais vu ça
ordinaire
et cette victoire donc de la France en
2014 qui nous prouve des choses à ne
jamais c'est vrai que forcément aimé
aussi que la victoire s'obtient par la
force du collectif alors justement dans
ma flamme en président de convergence
réseau associatif de TPE et PME dans les
Yvelines et l'Essonne vous étendez sur
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines Versailles
Grand Parc le plateau de Saclay ce
collectif justement comment vous vous
mettez en forme comment vous fonctionnez
pour initier tu sais projet collaboratif
contre les entreprises de de ces
territoires
et bien on se réunit régulièrement je
pense que le tempo est important il faut
vraiment des échéances bien bien établie
donc on se réunit régulièrement on
échange les plus anciens aide les plus
nouveau le plus récent échange
d'expériences sur le problème de
management sur les problèmes de
recherche de subvention sur les
problèmes de
créer un pour recherche de créer une
relation est sur comment passer les
moments difficiles comme par exemple
cette crise donc on s'est serré pour
passer les épreuves compliqué et dans la
liste vous avez cité on a aussi le club
des entrepreneurs de jouet qui vient
élargir un peu notre groupe donc on va
chercher un or not de notre ville en
fait dans le territoire des Yvelines
d'autres partenariat avec d'autres club
d'entrepreneurs qui ont la même approche
convergence représente quoi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et qui regroupe qu'on a coupé en deux
thèmes un thème qui avait la Smart City
d'ailleurs c'est le nouveau nom de
convergence quand Jean Smart City sur
des thèmes environnement énergie
mobilité et là on est en train de lancer
un nouveau un nouveau pôle en
cybersécurité ou plus exactement comment
aider les entreprises à lutter contre
les effets de la cyberattaque
que cela peut avoir
de travailler ensemble
je
veux aller partager mon expérience
on a réussi à faire quelques quelques
webinar pendant la période de
confinement mais pas autant que je
souhaitais et le redémarrage est
beaucoup plus long que prévu en fait je
pense que l'activité est repartie mais
beaucoup reste encore à la maison donc
tu n'as pas et tu n'es pas revenu à
l'identique donc il y a une forte
demande de se rencontrer et de jouer
collectif
votre métier accompagner les
PMC chef d'entreprise
qui sont souvent seul
du chef d'entreprise
qui sont à la tête de leur propre
entreprise et
puis
et puis
Jean et anticiper pour vous êtes à la
recherche de solutions et les solutions
bah on se regarde des uns les autres
entrepreneurs entre chef d'entreprise
pour dire bon alors face à ce problème
c'est ce qui se passe avec avec les
entreprises dans le réseau convergence
et on se regarde voir comment on fait
face à cette situation qu'on connait pas
et là pour le coup on a besoin
finalement bête collective dans le fait
de trouver des idées nouvelles pour des
problèmes nouveau qu'on avait pas
forcément imaginer qui s'impose à nous
et donc c'est quand même la survie de
nos entreprises donc c'est pas un petit
sujet et aujourd'hui une entreprise qui
se replie sur elle-même et une
entreprise qui se met en danger donc
faut quand même bien ça présent et pour
un entrepreneur souvent c'est pas
toujours facile de sortir de chez lui
s'ouvrir vers l'extérieur c'est pas
toujours naturel pour tout le monde et
le plus sur expert technique et moi
c'est naturel et pourtant ça fait partie
du job de chef d'entreprise de savoir
s'entourer d'aller regarder à
l'extérieur donc ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui même quand on monte son
entreprise en a pas forcément la logique
de il va falloir que on voit tout de
suite à l'extérieur on vient vous voir
une fois qu'on est face aux difficultés
pas nécessairement parce que en fait
les difficultés généralement c'est pas
toujours un sujet dans ton s'ouvre comme
ça facilement et puis on fait une
recherche sur internet et puis on va
dire non d'abord le premier secours
c'est l'expert-comptable c'est c'est
l'homme de confiance par essence qui est
présent au niveau des filles qui connaît
les procédures bon mais la difficulté
des entreprises au départ des
décorations de l'utilisation des
ressources dental dispose et donc quand
tu en parles de ressources sont les
ressources financières et ressources
techniques et les ressources humaines et
c'est la façon vous utilisez là vous
allez sur un terrain de stratégie est-ce
que j'ai la bonne stratégie
l'utilisation de mes ressources dans un
contexte et en plus de ça je dois faire
face à des crises comment je dois
redéployer mes numéros de sauce dans
quel ordre pour pouvoir assurer la
survie d'entreprise parce que ça a été
souvent le cas pour beaucoup
d'entreprises ces derniers mois
qu'est-ce qu on vous demande le plus
souvent comment développer son réseau
comment ouvrir son capital comment
devenir une qui se développer son
business à la photo déjà c'est difficile
de répondre à cette question parce que
chaque entreprise et donc il y a pas une
une une réponse unique face à ça mais je
dirais que pour commencer à regarder un
peu le problème faut s'intéresser c'est
quoi qui constituent mon métier c'est
les savoir-faire de l'entreprise qui
vont faire qu'à un moment donné
qu'est-ce que j'ai des livres à mes
clients pour qui a quel bénéfice ça leur
apporte comment je maintiens un avantage
concurrentiel et ça c'est dans le métier
dans le savoir-faire intrinsèque de
l'entreprise qu'il faut aller fouiller
et c'est ce qui constitue la base et
bien souvent et ça donne lieu à des
entreprises qui con qui coopèrent
ensemble comme chez Bernard ou chez
Christophe qui elle pour le coup bah
c'est un un conglomérat finalement
quelques sortes d'entreprises qui vont
réunir ce qu'elles savent très bien
faire pour pouvoir proposer parce
qu'elles sont pas forcément la puissance
de feu d'une entreprise beaucoup plus
grande et là encore ce sont aussi des
choix de stratégie dire bon je n'ai pas
forcément vocation à internaliser tel ou
telle compétence donc où je vais la
chercher à l'extérieur ou une autre
entreprise qui est en capacité de
coopérer avec avec ce que je sais faire
pour aller plus vite plus grand plus
loin
par rapport
au marché
[Musique]
réunir certainement de société où
chacune des noms concurrentes entre elle
met ensemble on va pouvoir sur chacun de
nos expertise avoir une offre plus
précise plus pointues pour nos clients
donc ça favorise le développement du
business en commun mais aussi à utiliser
ses ressources que sur ce qu'on doit se
développer et pas se focaliser parce
qu'un client nous demander à un endroit
on va mobiliser nos ressources
d'entreprise nous ressources humaines
pas au bonne endroit recruter des gens
c'est long alors qu'en fait avec un
partenaire qui est très bon dans le
domaine des bas à plusieurs on va être
meilleur vis-à-vis de nos clients part
de marché de marché qu'on aurait pas vu
et qu'on aurait pas eu par contre on
doit pas se substituer 100 %
de l'entreprise
ça
va pas non plus
et puis
quelle heure économique se sont les mots
qui conviennent le mieux exactement et
commercial tous les trois on comprend
bien aujourd'hui pour les TPE et PME
rester seule option les chefs
d'entreprise échanger entre faire les
bons choix à travailler ensemble donc je
vais me reposer la question et forcément
l'actualité ne nous y oblige aussi la
situation covit est-ce que ça a rendu ce
constat encore plus vrai aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous l'avez constaté la
situation de crise covid celle qui est
passé et l'éventuelle vague qu'on nous
annoncent encore aujourd'hui
malheureusement dans ce genre de calvin
SD
ça peut être compliqué les échanges ont
été d'une autre nature au lieu de parler
de technique ou de l'agglomération de
l'agrégation de service pour faire une
offre globale on a parlé de
complémentarité entre celui qui sait
travailler
le métier celui qui c'est le vendre et
les comptables besoin expliquer
Charleroi expliquer expliquer la notion
de besoin de trésorerie le BFR les 60
ans et beaucoup ont été surpris de voir
vous pouvez juste mourir parce qu'on
avait une croissance trop rapide par
exemple donc c'est des sujets qui ce qui
est sorti le cadre on a une vision
globale et je pense que c'est positif
c'est ouvert un peu plus fort
énorme
sur
elle
sincère dans un écosystème dans son dans
son commerce dans son dans son secteur
d'activité et ça a amené beaucoup
d'entreprises serez interrogé sur ce
qu'elle proposait puisque certains
secteurs d'activité comme ça s'arrête
s'arrête et puis bah ils sont même en
difficulté donc un moment donné vous
avez quand même encore des factures et
des salaires à payer nous avons été très
bien aidé par par l'État qui a mis des
dispositifs pertinent efficace mais il
faut aussi à ce moment-là commençais
déjà à préparer la sortie de crise très
en amont et donc c'est ce réinterroger
quelque part sur le la configuration de
son activité est-ce que un secteur
d'activité qui est sinistrée tous les
secteurs d'activité n'ont pas été non
plus totalement sinistre et donc c'était
énormément à lui en se met en fonction
de votre profil de société d'activité
vous êtes plus ou moins exposée et un
moment donné vous réinterroger ce que je
disais tout à l'heure vos savoir-faire
pour dire bon bah finalement ce que je
sais bien faire Akil finalement ça peut
être bénéfique et pour certains c'est
une prise de conscience qui leur
permettra aussi de diversifier les
secteurs d'activité donc de réduire les
risques d'exposition un secteur
d'activité qui peut être en difficulté
donc on repense littéralement la façon
dont ton a son son activité et et ça
pour le coup ça permettra des
entreprises a beaucoup d'entreprises de
rebondir plus fort et d'être beaucoup
plus solide aussi par la suite il y a
pas d'autres problèmes à résoudre mais
en tout cas déjà on entre dans un mode
de raisonnement qui est vertueux
la joie collectif justement je me tourne
vers vous à présent est-ce que les TPE
et PME qui ce jeu-là dès le début et
qu'il avait intégrer avant même la
situation aussi mieux résister en dehors
des aides de l'État bien sûr qu'il y a
un réseau qui est déjà en place
moi je sais que je pense la crise cette
crise a été un accélérateur une prise de
conscience pour beaucoup de patron
d'entreprise
il faut être plus collaboratif parce
qu'on accède beaucoup plus rapidement à
des solutions des échanges de
l'expérience très opérationnelle quand
vous avez le couteau sous la gorge quand
vous avez pu te la faire vous avez plus
rien on reparle de PG comment le fais je
dois mettre du chômage partiel comment
je fais exetera exetera quand vous êtes
dans un dans un cluster comme nous moi
genari son vous fait partie de bébé il y
a accéléré dans le
automobile on accédait on live
ce qui se passait les dispositifs des
explications techniques à bien
évidemment évidemment tous les chefs
d'entreprises qui était donc plus
bénéficier de ça pour mettre en place
immédiatement les dispositifs adapté à
ce qui leur correspondent je pense que
ça mon quand on a une crise on se trouve
c'est là qu'on se rend compte qu'on
connait pas tu maîtrises pas tu es que
c'est bien d'avoir un autre appareil
expert-comptable mais il y a plein
d'autres AXA ils sont là on se rend
compte qu'on va très vite pour la prise
de décision la décision déjà tous les
jours la décision fondamental dans une
crise elle est encore plus fondamentale
et ça a aidé à faire ça nous ça nous a
permis très vite de passer les bonnes
pratiques les bonnes idées
chose là qu'on peut lui stressé on est
passé en covit il fallait continuer la
production pour ceux qui avait du
physique
l'écosystème a énormément marché sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines des masques
des gens qui sont mis en fer à côté ça a
été on a fait un club de bonnes
pratiques des gens qui était plutôt déjà
dans la chimie qui connaissait bien des
bons processus en fait on voit vraiment
que le collaboratif est fondamental pour
pour une prise de conscience une
accélération de l'envie de collaboratif
si tu as déclenché aussi un mouvement de
solidarité finalement à faire les uns
les autres parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'entraide qui c'est qui s'est mise en
place parce qu'on avait tous finalement
les mêmes problèmes se sert survive mon
entreprise
moyen pour être plus performant c'est la
thématique de cette table ronde cette
émission que vous proposons sur TV 78
dans le cadre du Skype si vous voulez
nous rejoindre 3 invités sont avec nous
au tour de table on l'a vu depuis le
début avec vous en ce sont des facs de
façon dont vous fonctionnez sur cluster
conseils aux dirigeants vous avez pu le
l'illustrer j'aimerais qu'on parle
peut-être des réalisations concrète que
vous avez pu mener Bernard Flament par
exemple pour convergence et il y a 3
immobilier service entreprise ou
particulier technologie innovation avec
la Smart City aussi les entreprises
membres de votre réseau
un moment fait des sociétés de
territoire pour trouver une solution
local
sur france 2 acteur majeur
et on a constaté que
jeux pour faire une offre complète
globale et qui me concerne j'avais le
contact avec la RATP développement au
niveau et donc on a fait venir le
responsable RATP développement et on lui
a présenté non pas dans une structure
cluster mais dans une structure
associative
la solution et pour poursuivre la
question pas forcément poser ça suffit
pas en fait RATP vois des compétences
complémentaires
intéressante mais elle a besoin d'avoir
un interlocuteur quelqu'un qui pilote et
donc la notion de Coster à mon avis est
plus pertinent en fait
une conclusion de cette et c'est qui n'a
pas été transformée c'est que il faut
qu'on puisse peut-être se rapprocher des
clusters pour mettre ensemble et en fait
on on aura plus de chantier arrivé mais
on a essayé de répondre ensemble à un
appel d'offre important
qui a montré le chemin donc on est en
train de refaire la même chose dans le
domaine cybersécurité sur la partie
assurantielle
mais juste vous êtes vous-même président
de société pie 93993 spécialisé dans le
secteur d'activité de du Commerce
vous voulez résultats vous avez pu vous
avez pu obtenir grâce à ce réseau
associatif aussi
dans votre activité économique
société qui
a
beaucoup d'autres
projets en
français
[Musique]
donc j'ai pas vraiment profiter de
j'irai de de convergence je dirais même
que à la sortie de cette expérience
négative en partie au covit station là
où j'ai accepté de prendre la présidence
de convergence pour rebondir et en même
temps à aider les autres à rebondir et
travailler collectif une fois de plus ce
que c'est un vieux aussi vous avez créé
un lieu parce qu'on parlait justement de
l'interlocuteur unique alors vous avez
créé un lieu à c'est inédit pour les
réalisations commune de ctpe PME son nom
c'est pas loin de sérieux unique sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on a déjà eu
l'occasion de le visiter de vous
présenter sur notre antenne on va revoir
d'ailleurs quelques images on y trouve
FabLab open space zone de créativité
classiques aussi présente structure
qu'on voit l'image d'ailleurs
votre côté par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit l'intérêt de pourquoi on a créé
c'est que dans notre dans le classeur et
de manière de délivrer nos prestations
on va bien évidemment d'idéation on va
faire la créativité avec des prototypes
mais on va faire tout ce qu'il y a un
générique mais on va aussi faire la
fabrication avec la logistique associé
donc on se retrouve finalement avoir une
chaîne vertical pour accompagner nos
clients ce qui intéresse grâce à 7h
agglomération de compétences de pouvoir
prendre de guider jusqu'au produit et
mais on devait faire cohabiter
simultanément différentes sociétés des
start-up plus con de l'Open innovation
avec nos clients qui éduque au
développement et des manières de travail
et qui va de l'intellectuel au physique
donc c'est pour ça qu'on l'a développer
parce que souvent on va voir une zone
d'activité en zone du bureau là c'est
relativement séparer si vous voulez des
boucles d'innovation cours de voulais
avoir de la capacité de réactivité il
faut pouvoir avoir à tous les étages
passer de la femme au bureau d'études au
FabLab exetera avec des boucles court
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a développé qui
permettait en même temps d'accueillir
l'ensemble des bois du cluster pour
favoriser la proximité pour avancer et
les échanges et puis offrir une offre
assez unique par rapport à nos clients
pour les accompagner les accompagner les
entreprises
aujourd'hui on voit bien la limite de ça
avec les modifications de travail le
télétravail et on a vraiment tout et
tout et reconfigurable à la durée au
mois donc on a des start-up qui viennent
encore qu'il y a la journée on a un qui
est dans la semaine on a nos clients
s'installe au mois avec 2 mois 3 mois le
temps du projet on est capable de
reconfigurer de le bâtiment permanence
par rapport aux besoins de projet le
projet qui sait
pas exactement
quand on
et on
appelle un démonstrateur a des mots car
dans lequel on prend une voiture il
fabrique pas de voiture dans lequel on
ils ont intégré Lorie innovation auquel
on a rajouté tout ce qui est
électronique tout ce qui est intégration
nécessaire pour rapport à leur piece
donc il avait une dizaine de start-up le
grand compte on a travaillé d'ailleurs
avec étude intégrale qui nous a fait
toute la partie intégration de protons
dans ce véhicule là et on a fait toutes
les lampes l'ensemble quasiment des
boîtes ont bossé dessus et ça c'est un
programme pour pour une ça c'est de l'or
d'amis en 5 2 million d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires vous prenez pas un programme
comme ça quand vous êtes petit vous
pouvez pas vous insérez donc ensemble
ensemble des membres plus de l'Open
innovation externe et notre client on a
pu faire des programmes de ce type là on
l'a fait aussi pour PSA dentiste pour le
groupe Renault on a réalisé ce type de
projet voilà donc avec quasiment on est
allés jusqu'à une dizaine d'acteurs
simultanément autour d'un projet et on
arrive à fonctionner comme ça quand je
rejoins c'est qu'il faut être capable
d'avoir une maîtrise donc qui va
coordonnées l'ensemble c'est ce que fait
Genaris dans le cluster en animant de
manière à ce que ce qui fait que ça
marche on collaborative dirait faut bien
voir définis les les modalités de
contractualisation entre chacun des
membres qui est pas de sous par rapport
à ça et c'est comme ça que ça marche
bien l'exercice du travail collectif
passe aussi par la centralisation il
faut
d'entreprise de ok je
ferais pas ça
tous les jours
alors que je sais vraiment
[Musique]
vite et ça facilite la possibilité de
carrière d'échange le dire bon bout d'un
moment j'ai fais tourner oh non j'ai
plein de choses à faire et grâce à ces
systèmes on peut rester longtemps et
capitaliser sur les ressources chez nous
tout à l'heure le succès du travail en
commun avec ses différents exemples de
vers vous à présent avec votre société
vous conseiller c'était CPME ctpe à
faire face bon choix à s'ouvrir aux
autres vouloir conseiller justement
aller vers des clusters travail en
association vous arrivez dans une
entreprise
[Musique]
à la question
tout à l'heure
parce que tous les
deux
ne sont pas forcément aller travailler
avec vous avez quand même des chefs
d'entreprise
avec un peu de Lego et il faut quand
même
arrivé à faire cohabiter des gens qui
ont des égaux et un moment donné tant
que les intérêts sont correctement
aligné je dirais bah tu vas bien le
soleil brille mais à partir du moment où
il y en a un qui se sent au milieu du
groupe finalement la 5e roue du carrosse
et qui trouve pas tout à fait son compte
là ça t'ira et comme vous avez des
attelages qui sont partis pour des
projets tels que la ratp des choses
comme ça en donner vous avez un chef de
file parce que si je peux demander grand
bonheur comme vous devez faire face à la
cohésion de l'ensemble du groupe là vous
avez quand même des entreprises avec des
structures juridiques indépendant même
si vous mettez des contrats il y a un
moment donné il faut savoir gérer des
désaccords alors les désaccords ça
existe dans un confit de configuration
comme celle-ci mais vous pouvez très
bien aussi la voir dans une
configuration d'une entreprise avec un
chef d'entreprise qui a un bord des
actionnaires et pour le calmer fort
quand même arriver à se mettre d'accord
parce que là c'est une façon de jouer
collectif 7 se constituer aussi
un bon pour le faire travailler parce
qu'en fait c'est quoi une gouvernance
une gouvernance et comment on met en
place une
organisation qui va permettre de se
projeter dans le futur de réfléchir à
des sujets pour après-demain c'est pas
pour des sujet opérationnel et donc
c'est les grandes décisions stratégiques
et là tout à l'heure dans votre question
vous parliez de comment comment
surmonter une crise de covit des
qu'est-ce qu'il y a plus passer pour un
certain de mes clients le choix il a été
tout simplement si je peux pas faire du
commerce
je vais me concentrer à investir et te
faire des gains de productivité nous
c'est la première axe que moi j'ai
poussé très fort c'est comment peut-on
mettre en place des gains de
productivité en travaillant différemment
en essayant de se réinventer en
réinventant également la façon dont tu
on peut proposer les offres et à qui
pourquoi et tout d'un coup on a on
dessine une nouvelle stratégie
finalement au fond donc on va utiliser
ses ressources différemment donc ça
aussi c'est jouer collectif parce que
vous avez les collaborateurs en interne
mais vous avez aussi au-dessus votre
board qui va pouvoir faire ça alors
après le jouer collectif plutôt sur des
clusters vous avez certaines
configuration d'activité c'est
parfaitement approprié vous pourrez
avoir aussi d'autres façons de
travailler qui pourrait par exemple un
réseau de franchise ou coopérative
associatif vous avez différentes formes
de coopération qui peuvent parfaitement
se mettre en œuvre mais tout dépend de à
la base de qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire pourquoi vous voulez le faire et
en quoi ça peut avoir un intérêt
finalement pour enrichir la ce que vous
proposez que finalement il faut qu'il y
a un bénéfice pour le client parce que
un client il achète un bénéfice plus que
la solution technique la solution
technique c'est celle qui est garance du
résultat de ce que vous allez délivrée
mais chaque entreprise chaque client un
besoin connu pas connu et des problèmes
à résoudre et finalement c'est le
bénéfice qui va apporter la réponse est
à l'édifice que vous mettez en place
collectifs avec de l'interne avec de
l'externe des partenariats où vous allez
avoir la réponse la plus pertinente qui
va convaincre finalement un client dire
bomber avant que je signe
et en fait il faut que la stratégie de
l'entreprise soit aligné avec le
collaborative sinon ça peut pas marcher
il faut vraiment
sinon c'est ce qu'on a prévu qu'est-ce
qu'on peut investir moi je cite un
exemple on va chercher un projet un gros
investissement on part il faut que tout
le monde soit capable de le suivre si en
cours de route il se rend compte ah non
mais je peux plus mais en l'air
l'équilibre qui a été fait voilà donc il
y a une vraie réflexion stratégique
avant de se lancer dans ce modèle et
après il y a d'autres modèles
alternative tout à fait d'accord qui
peut qui peut aller très bien aussi il
faut poser la question de la stratégie
et on a un modèle après à mettre en
œuvre
[Musique]
pour
comme ça ça fonctionne bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
sûr de gagner le business c'est même pas
une option que c'est obligatoire et
quand on challenge ce truc là en disant
mais pourquoi vous faites on vous
propose un ensemble de service pourquoi
mettre une structure au-dessus à la
limite c'est peut-être représenter un
coup sur le long terme fait la réponse
du grand groupe et l'acheter en
particulier c'est de dire oui mais
d'accord mais en cas de problème qui est
monté et comment je
récupère donc
voilà voilà comment réagissent les deux
et la deuxième c'est que en France c'est
est particulièrement présent et pour
avoir une carrière un peu international
j'ai pu constater que les Américains se
pose pas trop de questions pour aller
chercher un business et parfois même
avec un produit pas tout à fait terminé
mais ils vont chercher après j'ai vu les
Allemands
chasseur me dis souvent en ce qui
concerne
avec un ego très parce que les gosses et
présent aussi évidemment mais ils savent
vraiment le rentrer pour aller gagner
ensemble et après chacun reprend son et
je trouve qu'en France c'est souvent et
peut-être un peu trop exacerber un peu
trop en avant et nous fait perdre du
business ou la constitution d'une équipe
au départ qui devrait être un gage de
succès fini par être
et on peut perdre la faire juste parce
que les gens se sont pas mis d'accord
jusqu'au bout ça qu'ils étaient d'accord
départ mais elle arrivait au moment du
partage d'un éventuel profite ils
peuvent se saborder. Donc j'ai vécu ça
plusieurs fois et je pense que ça fait
partie des choses qu'on transmets dans
le cadre de convergence ce qu'ils ont
vécu explique aux autres que un peu
d'humidité dans l'objectif de gagner le
projet c'est pas mal compris
ce qu'il vienne vous rejoindre
national
[Rires]
mets le chrono 6 images du match de
rugby du 15 de France
une belle une belle réaction collective
d'orgueil aussi et on a vu sur sur un
coude action un retournement
spectaculaire c'est exactement ce qu'on
a vu également dans la vidéo après c'est
comment il faut bien comprendre pour un
chef d'entreprise où est l'intérêt vital
de son entreprise
et quand on se pose correctement la
question où sont les enjeux et bien ce
moment alors comment ça a donné des
réponse pertinente si je suis pas assez
gros pour aller chercher un business et
que c'est vers la que je veux temps donc
il faut que je paraisse plus gros que je
ne suis et ça arrive fréquemment avec
des gros donneur d'ordre et bien il faut
y aller en collectif il faut pas y aller
il faut pas y aller tout seul parce que
c'est votre crédibilité à pouvoir
assumer un projet que certains vont les
grands donneur d'ordre ont commencé à
vous dire attendez je vais représenter
un taille poids de chiffre d'affaires
dans votre activité que moi j'ai pas
envie de prendre le risque juridique
d'être embarqué si vous arrive une
catastrophe donc il y a une question de
lucidité de discernement sur les enjeux
et le niveau de risque qui est pris dans
les choix que l'on fait
sur la façon de travailler aussi parce
que vous intervenez auprès des
entreprises pour les pour les
conseillers ça peut être très court
comme ça peut être très long comment ça
fonctionne pour ceux qui me suivent et
qui ont besoin de conseils personnalisés
c'est
très varié voilà c'est très varié mais
généralement mes interventions ont des
effets sur le temps long c'est-à-dire
qu'il s'agit de créer les conditions
d'un développement qui va rencontrer les
aspirations profondes d'un chef
d'entreprise
ce chef d'entreprise il est pris dans un
quotidien on a parlé de la sud mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui rattrapé par
l'opérationnel au quotidien qui doit
s'occuper des services généraux qui est
l'assistante sociale il est multi
casquette
pris au milieu
obligation réglementaire donc c'est un
peu particulier et dans lequel c'est pas
toujours de confort
pour pouvoir donner de l'élan de
l'énergie dans pour un entrepreneur ça
passe par ici aussi de autorisé à rêver
de s'autoriser être ambitieux mais
comment on construit une ambition
finalement
ça suppose de prendre conscience de où
sont véritablement ses forces parce que
on bâtit un projet de développement sur
les forces d'une entreprise et les
forces je vais revenir sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est le
savoir-faire qu'est-ce qu'on maîtrise
bien et pour qui c'est pertinent et
quand on pose correctement les données
du problème et c'est ce que je fais avec
eux c'est d'abord où vous voulez aller
définition où nous voulons venir quel
est le niveau de performance qu'on veut
atteindre le niveau de performance c'est
pas nécessairement est le numéro 1 de
telle ou telle chose ça se définit pas
forcément comme étant je veux atteindre
tel niveau de chiffre d'affaires c'est
parfois des critères purement
qualitative donc une fois qu'on a défini
un petit peu là où on veut se rendre et
bien c'est là que la stratégie va
véritablement intervenir et donc là je
les aide effectivement je leur propose
la stratégie qui me paraît la plus
pertinente en rapport du projet des
photos ciel de l'entreprise donc déjà
avoir un diagnostic stratégique pour
savoir quels sont les potentiels là on
serait plutôt dans la réponse du
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire rapidement a
déjà commencé à prendre conscience des
réel potentiel le paiement de
l'entreprise et des possibles et de
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire et
qu'est-ce qui est fait pour moi
qu'est-ce qui n'est pas fait pour moi en
tant que dirigeant d'entreprise puis
après ça bon bah il y a tout le sujet de
l'accompagnement de l'exécution de la
mise en opération de
la stratégie pour que ça après viennent
se décliner se jouer au niveau des
équipes et se mettre en œuvre et sachant
qu'il y a beaucoup de Régis sur lequel
il faut agir pour terminer cette
émission une barrière si elle existe ou
pas vous me le direz est-ce que
l'entreprise qui hésite à jouer
collectif se disent aussi
tout à l'heure et la concurrence aussi
est-ce que est-ce que je me dévoile un
peu trop en collaborant avec une autre
entreprise qui éventuellement pour
intervenir sur le même secteur que moi
que ça peut arriver ça comme ça
quelquefois qui s'exprime et il faudrait
rassurer pour ceux qui voudraient pas
encore mettre collectif
alors la réponse est oui il y a une
grande pudeur on va dire
on fait beaucoup de réunion ou
finalement il se dit pas grand-chose
parce que
justement
ils sont
sur le même sujet
modification faire le français reste à
ces paysans
beaucoup de choses
après effectivement moi je te parle
c'est naturel un petit peu d'avoir peur
de la Conférence Est comprends les
choses mais nous donc le soir c'est un
peu différent ce que nous on a fait dans
le nôtre c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de
concurrence entre une personne d'entrée
de jeu parce que tout simplement on
répond dans notre manière de faire c'est
toutes les compétences complémentaires
qu'on a pas non par nature on a pas de
concurrence entre les entre les mains
pour avoir été avec dans l'associatif
moi j'ai travaillé avec des concurrents
il y a pas de problème partir du moment
parce que j'ai bien aimé ce que tu as
dit c'est le business en fait on y va à
plusieurs parce que on va pouvoir en
prendre plus un moment avec des
concurrents est-ce que le client il y en
a beaucoup il est rassuré que il est de
boîte dans le dans le collectif qui vont
savoir-faire et si on a une qui est
défaillante y en a une autre il y a
toujours de quoi faire ensemble faut pas
avoir peur on en revient la stratégie
quelle valeur je veux où je veux aller
est-ce que je dois être tout seul je
veux pas donner je suis le premier je
veux rien faire et Jean voir tendance à
dire je vais rester seul si on est pas
dans ce cadre-là il y a pas de problème
le collaboratif y a de la place pour
tout le monde
on a finalement
il aurait pu faire tout seul tout seul
mais un peu moins bien sur notre partie
avec les
petits
alors
on peut quand même
parce que je pense que dans une
entreprise
entreprise on a un tracé comment
accepter une notion de risque donc la
concurrence oui bien sûr c'est un risque
mais si on commence à regarder tous les
sujets comme étant en finalement un
problème plus qu'un défi la autant
rester chez soi donc moi je dis je
préfère aller relever des défis plutôt
que de me dire zut encore un problème à
résoudre et puis la concurrence c'est
aussi ce qui permet d'être aussi dans la
compétition et envie pas tout seul
encore une fois puisque le sujet c'est
dire jouer collectif mais la confiance
c'est aussi une façon de jouer collectif
d'avoir des des adversaires sur votre
terrain de jeu même vous dire quand vous
commencez à lancer vous avez une idée
géniale aujourd'hui vous êtes tout début
marché il existe pas forcément mais
quand vous êtes tout seul pour lancer sa
évangéliser faire connaître sur un
marché vous êtes tout seul il vous en
faut du temps et l'énergie pour ça et si
vous commencez à être plusieurs tout
d'un coup bah vous allez plus vite et ça
c'est tout de suite vous avez un an
accélération au niveau du marché vous
fait émerger et bien finalement dans ce
cas là ça commence à devenir tout à fait
vers tu veux quand on regarde la
concurrence comme ça je veux collectif
un moyen pour être plus performant c'est
thématique de la Table Ronde je vous en
prie j'ai passé un petit tour de temps
pour conclure mais je vous en prie
pas été aussi performant s'il y avait
pas eu
il faut avoir en fait il faut avoir un
mental d'acier faut vraiment
aller à fond et on y arrive
à plusieurs c'est pour ça que la gare de
belge et à cheval
c'est un accélérateur pour moi c'est un
accélérateur et partage d'expérience
pour la personne y a pas de problème
c'est très bien il pourra que gagner
on n'a jamais on n'a jamais raison tout
seul donc il faut partager ces idées les
tester donc forcément fausse ouvert vers
l'extérieur donc le collectif c'est le
quotidien puis on crée pas une
entreprise pour être tout seul dans son
pain merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à notre antenne dans le cadre
du Skype business vais à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à cette
émission cette table ronde et bien sûr
possible de revoir à l'intégralité de
vos interventions sur notre site
internet en replay est le site Internet
de vos différents groupes aussi sont
affichées pour celles et ceux qui
voudraient savoir un petit peu plus et
puis chef d'entreprise si vous ne suivez
vous pouvez si vous tournez vers
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et puis le ski
cube qui regroupe incubateur Maison de
l'Entreprise outils de financement aussi
et là les informations s'affiche pas à
l'écran à très bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]